[Music]
well in just the past hour the final
debate has got underway over whether to
impeach the President of the United
States Democrats and Republicans in the
House of Representatives are making
their case about whether Donald Trump
violated the Constitution
he's accused of withholding aid to
Ukraine to pressure it into
investigating his political rival the
Democrat controlled house is expected to
make Trump the third president to be
impeached in US history while Trump has
just called the process on social media
an assault on America well Democratic
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi opened
that debate calling for both sides to
put aside their partisanship and vote in
the interest of the country it is tragic
that the president's reckless actions
make impeachment necessary
he gave us no choice what we are
discussing today is the established fact
that the president violated the
Constitution it is a matter of fact that
the president is an ongoing threat to
our national security and the integrity
of our elections the basis of our
democracy
hundreds of historians legal scholars
and formal prosecutors regardless of
party had stated that the president
committed impeachable offenses while
Trump's Republican allies said that the
Democrats have been trying to impeach
the president since he was elected we on
the Republican side have no problem
taking our case to the majority into the
people of this country because they
elected Donald Trump and it is a matter
for the voters not this house not in
this way not in the way this is being
done it is trampled everything this
house believes in I said it yesterday
and I believe it to be this true today I
will fight this on process which has
been deplorable to use a word of the
majority it has been awful the calendar
and the clock make it impress it that we
actually do it quickly we don't care
about rules we don't care about minority
hearing days we don't care about giving
the opportunity for witnesses to be
called because the Chairman gets to
determine what is relevant well in a
moment will speak child White House
correspondent Kimberly how could but
first let's go to Heidi Joe Castro who
is on Capitol Hill where that vote will
happen
Heidi we've been seeing these really
impassioned speeches on the hill today
talk us through what we've been hearing
from both sides sure so we're only about
one hour into this the six hours
established rules for the debate and
it's been very contentious and of course
partisan you heard from Nancy Pelosi who
opened these debates saying that the
president's reckless actions gave
Congress no choice but to proceed down
this impeachment and she said that the
founding fathers of the country
envisioned a republic that would not be
under threat as it is from what she says
as the ongoing national security risk
that Trump's actions poses now by the
end of this evening we do expect this
historic vote to take place and it's not
a question of whether or not Trump will
be impeached Democrats who hold it
majority in the House of Representatives
certainly have the numbers to pass these
articles of impeachment what we're
looking at is how many Democrats might
defect from their party caucus we know
of at least one or two who have said
that they will not vote to impeach Trump
but there are no Republicans who have
said that they will so we expect this to
go down very narrowly partisan lines and
particularly we're looking at some of
these Democrats who represent districts
that are conservative that actually
voted for Trump in the last presidential
election and a handful of them have said
that they've come off of the fence on
this impeachment question and they have
decided to vote to approve the
impeachment explaining the reasons they
said it's because they feel compelled to
hold their constitutional duty to
oversee the president and they do this
knowing full well that they may pay the
political price with their constituents
in their conservative districts Heidi
Joe Castro there live for us on Capitol
Hill we'll be talking to Heidi a lot
more today Thank You Heidi for now well
let's now also go to Kimberly Hackett
who's our White House correspondent
Kimberly you're outside the White House
and I imagine the president is watching
pretty closely inside I see that he's
just tweeted in the last few minutes all
in caps such atrocious lies by the
radical left do
nothing Democrats this is an assault on
America and an assault on the Republican
Party so no surprises there right
Kimberly well there's no surprise I
guess that the president is defending
himself in the strongest and most
passionate of terms given the fact that
the president put forward a six-page
letter on the eve of this vote making
some of the very same points one of the
other points that the White House press
secretary has made in just the last hour
as we can confirm the president is
watching these proceedings we are told
Stephanie Gresham telling reporters that
he is doing that in between the meetings
that he is conducting and that tweet
that you just read a moment ago
certainly indicative of how the
president is reacting now in the midst
of all of this the president has also
retweeted one of his own tweets from
earlier in the day where he said I did
nothing wrong this should never happen
to another president again
say a prayer certainly the president
maintains and has been making the
argument repeatedly that this is a
partisan coup a line that is very clear
in his six page letter to the House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi one that she
responded calling sick this is a back
and forth that has been taking place and
the arguments being made by this
president whether on Twitter whether in
his letter or whether by his defenders
in the House of Representatives is that
it is motivated to try and undo the
results of the 2016 US election one that
ultimately if when the president is
impeached and we believe that will
happen later today that the voters will
have the opportunity to weigh in on come
November 2020 Camberley I see that the
president has cleared his schedule for
most of the day but then he's headed for
the seemingly aptly-named Battle Creek
for a rally later Battle Creek Michigan
yeah Battle Creek is very fitting you're
right and so is the state that he's
going to given the fact that this is one
of the swing states that helped decide
the election back in 2016 and also
notable is the fact that when we look at
the poll numbers well the nation is
divided in terms of whether or not to
pitch Donald Trump what we notice
is that in these key battleground states
Michigan being one of them
Wisconsin is another and the third one
escapes me at the moment but the point
is is that in those states support for
the US president is actually rising
there's pushback on what many people are
starting to call impeachment fatigue if
you will and this campaign is certainly
seizing on that Donald Trump will be
leaving the White House later today
he'll be going to Battle Creek and what
we're setting up possibly is a very
interesting split-screen moment that
really sums up where America is right
now because simultaneously as we see
this vote potentially coming down on the
other side of Americans TV screens will
be the hundreds even thousands of
supporters who back the President and
are opposed to his impeachment Kimberly
halket there White House correspondent
Thank You Kimberly well we'll leave it
there for now and speak to Clyde Wilcox
who's a professor of government at
Georgetown University here in Doha
can I just picking up on something that
Kimberly was talking about there she was
talking about impeachment fatigue is
there impeachment fatigue already I mean
we're just starting potentially a very
long Senate trial in January how is the
public perceiving this whole process do
they even want to see a trial go forward
you know the public is not paying a lot
of attention because the details are
complicated into two obscure for the
public to pay much attention to Trump
supporters are buying his line that he
did nothing wrong but you know imagine a
different world where Donald Trump was a
different man
where he could say I did something wrong
here where he could be like Bill Clinton
and say you know as I had this phone
call it seemed bright but now that I
look at it it was over the line and then
we didn't have Republicans saying he did
nothing wrong you know there's no
Republican in Congress who really thinks
he did nothing wrong here right in that
kind of world it wouldn't be so divisive
it wouldn't be so partisan but Donald
Trump is never going to be that man he's
going to go there and say they're trying
to have a coup which of course is not
what's going on do you think that we
might see him actually testify in the
Senate trial Donald Trump couldn't go
two minutes without perjuring himself
setting that aside is there the room for
any senator
it's potentially to defect I know
everything's been so partisan in the
house and you know we've seen only one
Republican House representative won't
desert his party and become an
independent in order to be able to vote
differently on the impeachment what do
we likely to see in the Senate you know
it's really hard to say but privately a
lot of Republican senators are voicing
deep concern about this activity and
about other kinds of activity that's
been going on another country someone
mentioned earlier what if what could
bolt and say well Bolton has been saying
privately in Washington that Trump was
pursuing business interests with Turkey
as part of the deal to withdraw troops
out of Syria so if he said that publicly
that would be a pretty big deal right so
if we will not have a secret ballot I
agree on that but if they did many
people would defect does anyone have the
courage to actually vote that way I
don't know maybe Mitt Romney maybe Susan
Collins I don't know well the Democrats
are making this a real constitutional
issue I mean Nancy Pelosi was incredibly
reluctant to begin this process in the
first place what's the political
calculus now for Republican senators
because there are some moderate
Republicans some vulnerable Republican
senators who will have to take that into
account going into an election yeah so
if you're thinking just politically
right only can I be re-elected then the
core of the Republican base is really
supportive of Donald Trump people who
are who have left who don't support
Donald Trump have left the party their
independence to become Democrats so you
would be really angry at a core of the
voters you absolutely need so that would
be a really tough vote to take but you
know you're supposed to be an impartial
juror so well let me ask you about this
there's one particular gentleman I
believe who's had a meeting with Donald
Trump last week and has decided to
defect from the Democratic Party well so
potentially well a number of his staff I
believe it also said that they will no
longer work for him so is there the
potential to go the other way in the
Senate as well that Democratic senators
might might leave yeah you could imagine
maybe Joe Manchin from West Virginia
voting against the conviction in the
case of the the House member from New
Jersey he was never going to win his
death
kradic primary so this is a pretty easy
call for him let me pick up on one thing
that we were talking about before the
break and that is there are no crimes
here one of the things that occurs to me
is that it's very surprising that the
Democrats didn't rely on the second half
in the Moller report which details at
least it was a shame about him to base
about whether that would be a third
right and and there were ten cases where
he talked about criminal obstruction of
justice I thought nine of them were
pretty convincing you could have picked
a few of those I'm really surprised
they've kept it so narrow but it has
become very divisive for the Democratic
Party and so this is potentially them
playing it safe then I think I think it
would have been safer to a guy more
broadly myself clyde wilcox a professor
at georgetown university here in Doha
we'll come back to you in a moment right
now I want to take you to live pictures
of Capitol Hill you're watching special
coverage here on al-jazeera because the
final debate has now gotten underway
over whether or not to impeach the
President of the United States House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi and her opening
remarks said that Trump by violating the
Constitution gave lawmakers no choice
but to pursue impeachment Trump is
facing charges of abusing his power and
obstructing Congress that impeachment
vote is expected in the coming hours
well patty Culhane is in Washington DC
for us to talk more about the
impeachment with a very special panel
patty over to you thanks welcome to
Washington it can't be overstated
understood this is a historic day just
the third president facing the
possibility of being impeached by the US
House of Representatives I have a great
panel joining us to talk about this
historic vote John Malcolm he's the vice
president of the Institute for
constitutional government at the
Heritage Foundation that's a
conservative think-tank here in
Washington
Robinson Woodward burns he's an
assistant professor at Howard University
specializing in constants to the
Constitution and Melanie Sloan a former
federal prosecutor and founding director
of Citizens for responsibility and
ethics in government John I want to
start with you thank you all for joining
us sure John you don't think they you
should be
peached why no for a variety of reasons
in addition to the fact that I don't
think the facts warrant impeachment you
know this is certainly been done in a
very partisan manner I mean you know
Jerry Nadler back in 1998 said the
following he said Jerry Nadler audience
doesn't yeah well he's the chairman of
the House Judiciary Committee and he
said back in 1998 at the time of the
Clinton impeachment hearing quote there
must never be a narrowly voted
impeachment when impeachment is
supported by one of our major political
parties and opposed by the other such an
impeachment will produce divisive news
and bitterness in our politics for years
to come
and will call into question the very
legitimacy of our political institutions
well at the end of the day today there
is going to be a very partisan vote I
don't think you are going to get any
Republicans voting in favor of
impeachment and you're going to probably
get one or two Democrats crossing over
in fact in voting with the Republican
here's the thing that's been really
troubling for me
being in Washington there are two sets
of facts right and that we're gonna have
spend six hours of the house Republicans
saying these are the facts Democrats
saying these are the facts facts are
actual actually facts that show do you
believe that it is a true that the
president told the president of Ukraine
that basically he could have his that
there was a quid pro quo do you believe
there was no facts are facts
but how one interprets those facts is
subject to reasonable differences and I
have believed since the very beginning
here that if you went into these
hearings believing that the president
was clearly undermining the national
interests of the United States and he
was doing so for a purely personal
partisan reason to gain an advantage
over a political rival then that is what
you believed and your view is that if he
strengthened if that's true if that were
true that would arguably constitute a
gross abuse of office which would be an
impeachable offense but the facts do not
support that we've had his own
ambassador to the European Union say
there was a quid pro quo and it seems to
the White House visit everybody was in
on it everybody knew about it and not a
transcript but it
from the White House saying in the call
you want to buy these missiles okay can
you do us a favor though the president
and not career diplomats within the
State Department get to determine what
foreign policy is the president stated
that he had three reasons why he was
skeptical of Ukraine one he has said on
numerous occasions that he believes that
the United States provides too much
foreign aid to other countries in
general okay didn't just he didn't do
this with Ukraine until Joe Biden said I
get well first of all even if that were
true and I'm not sure that is true the
president said that he had to concerns
about Ukraine which were presented as
false narratives by career diplomats one
is that he was concerned about potential
Ukrainian interference in the 2016
election and two he was concerned about
whether or not the Ukrainians had truly
turned over a new lead in about
investigating corruption with that in
cont within that country and that
includes purísima and that includes Joe
Biden who was at the time the Vice
President of the United States during
the Obama administration and if there is
a factual predicate that would support
that investigation and I believe there
was the president is fully within his
power to ask a foreign government to
assist with an investigation into
corruption Melanie are there two sets of
facts here there aren't two sets of fact
there's only one set of facts and that
is that the president asked that aide be
that US aid be held up until szalinski
announced an investigation of hunter
Biden he didn't even care if there was
an actual investigation he just wanted
them to announce one and I don't think
that the Republicans are very much
focused on the facts that's the facts
really aren't helping them here which is
why they keep talking about the process
they go over and over that this is an
unfair process again also leaving out
that part of the reason that it is quick
and that there has been less testimony
is because the administration is
stonewalling Congress has refused to put
people before has refused to hand over
any documents and has not allowed its
top officials to testify but Melanie or
former former federal prosecutor there
is an argument that the Democrats could
have waited for the courts to weigh in
they already have it at least in the
case of Don Magan and said there is no
blanket executive privilege these people
have to go before Congress this is
legitimate subpoena why not wait isn't
that pretty much just about the politics
of the election I think there's no
question that they could have waited and
they could have gone to court but that
would have taken an exceedingly long
time and they were as Nancy Pelosi has
had very worried about the integrity of
the American electoral system and what's
going to happen in the 2020 election and
they didn't feel like they could any
longer wait while Republicans just tried
to stymie and Stonewall any
investigation Robertson one of the
things I think is an interesting point
the Republicans keep making is that this
is going to set a precedent that we are
going to enter a time where every
president gets impeached is that a
legitimate concern the Constitution
gives the house broad leeway to
understand what sort of impeachable
offenses President may or may not have
committed and the Senate of course has
the authority to try those it is
intentionally left to the legislature to
determine the process now we do have an
increasingly polarized partisan scene in
which it is possible that this could
happen again but it is consistent with
the constitutional structure we have to
allow Congress to determine whether an
offense is impeachable or not let's look
ahead because I think everybody knows
what's gonna happen the house is going
to vote to impeach Donald Trump the only
third president to actually have that
put next to his name in the history
books for for all eternity but the
Senate that's the wild card here they
have to take a note that they will be
impartial but we've already seen the
Senate Medora Mitch McConnell come out
say yeah we're not gonna have witnesses
we're not gonna be impartial he's not
gonna be impeached
how do you square that as John as a
constitutional expert and knowing what
the precedent is and where we're
supposed to be with where we're going -
sure first of all by the way I'm also a
former federal prosecutor and at some
point I would like to address something
that Melanie just said but I'll go
directly to your question which is the
Constitution gives the House of
Representatives the sole power to
impeach and it gives the Senate the sole
power to try impeachments there have
already been a ton of witnesses who have
been called the house has been able to
call or they were impatient and not
waiting until the courts had ruled all
of the witnesses whom they wish to call
12 and this
penis were rejected by the white house
first of all they they subpoena John
Bolton and when John Bolton went to
court they withdrew the subpoena in
addition to that but they had actually
been winning at the lower level of the
federal courts but in their rush to get
this done they are not prepared to let
you can't legitimately say that the they
were allowed to testify Mick Mulvaney
the what acting the chief of staff of
the President everyone who would have
first-hand knowledge was not allowed to
talk so I'll give you another quote this
comes from an office of legal counsel
opinion from the Department of Justice
issued by the holder Justice Department
July 15 2014 the executive branch's
long-standing position reaffirmed by
numerous administration to both
political parties is that the
president's immediate advisors are
absolutely immune from congressional
testimonial process this immunity is
rooted in constitutional separation of
powers and the immunity of the President
himself and congressional compulsion to
testify if the house if the House
Democrats wanted to push that in court
which they have done from Mulvaney they
could do that for Bolton they could do
that for any number of these witnesses
all of a sudden say abuse of Congress I
mean if we are now going to be
impeaching presidents who assert an
executive privilege in response to a
congressional subpoena then every
president from now until the end of time
will end up being impeached because if
that's an impeachable offense every
president has done the courts over ruled
that well I worry about here is that the
refusal to turn over any documents and
that is not in fact within their proof
within their objective privilege is
executive privilege if the executive
branch has demanded these documents from
Congress Congress would be screaming
that they don't have to turn it we just
had a ruling from a federal judge who
said there is no blanket executive
privilege from a federal district court
judge that has an alsophila judge yes
and you have an appeal process and the
president has availed himself of an
appeal and rather than wait until that
appeal process works its way out and
then letting the process play out the
Democrats have instead said no we're
going to claim that we were absolutely
entitled to this
that you know any privilege that the
President does asserted is a bunch of
bunk and we're going to impeach him for
it
that is outlandish in the extreme now
the answer to the question that you
asked which is it is up to the house to
bring charges they can bring those
charges however they want to bring
charges it is not up to the Senate to
make up for deficiencies that occurred
in the in the investigation process in
the House of Representatives and the
Senate will decide after horse-trading I
assume the precise parameters of what
that trial will look like Melanie I'm
gonna let you wait on this but first
Robinson you're the constitutional
expert here is there supposed to be a
trial in the Senate and this excuse me
that we keep hearing from Republicans as
the house had their shot they didn't get
it where we're not responsible for
actually finding evidence what does the
Constitution say are they responsible
for having a trial they are the
Constitution gives fairly broad leeway
for the House and Senate to interpret
their duties the actual impeachment
clauses are fairly brief and one of the
ways we can understand the processes
through Federalist paper 65 in which
Hamilton describes it as a political
process and that doesn't mean a partisan
one but a legislative one this is the
way that the House and Senate can check
an executive of the executive over steps
it's part of the separation of power
systems we use now that separation of
powers requires that both chambers able
to broadly interpret how these processes
work and the Senate will likely draw on
rules that came out of the Andrew
Johnson impeachment of 1867 and 68 and
probably followed that long-standing
historical precedent and their general
what does that look like is there going
to be an actual trial if they were to go
back to the 1800s
the trial works a bit differently from
what we might think of as a conventional
trial members of the house are those who
explained the charges against the
President and senators act as an
impartial jury it requires a two-thirds
majority to remove the president so it's
a bit different from a trial way we
think of it but it is a clearly
explained process and we through the
precedent we have okay so Melanie do you
think that there's going to be a trial
you do you want to respond to his
argument that the president's been
transparent he has executive the
executive privilege the president
clearly hasn't been transparent at all
as I said they've been stonewalling the
investigation refusing to turn over
document
there have been interest groups that
have been able to go to court and get
documents from the administration
through the Freedom of Information Act
litigation that the the State Department
for example has refused to turn over to
Congress themselves you have to look at
this more like the house was if we put
it in more common parlance like the
grand jury and you get witnesses before
the grand jury and then you bring the
matter over to the Senate for actually a
full-blown trial so this idea that
because the House already called anybody
that they should there'd be no
additional witnesses in the Senate it's
actually kind of crazy if we look at our
regular criminal justice system oh there
are witnesses brought before a grand
jury and then when you have a trial
there are witnesses brought at trial
the reason that we're not gonna have
witnesses at trial is because senator
Mitch McConnell the majority leader
doesn't want any he doesn't want there
to be this spectacle in the Senate he
knows it will hurt the Republican Party
he knows it if Mick Mulvaney and john
bolton come and testify truthfully about
what they knew about this whole matter
it will go very badly for the president
and mitch mcconnell has already as
malcolm has mr. malcolm i said as
pre-baked the outcome and they want this
to be over as quickly as possible they
don't want any more bad facts with
president but here's I think what's
getting lost in the American media Mitch
McConnell doesn't have the final say
there are four Senate Republicans that
are retiring they don't have to worry
about being primary there are other
senators all it takes is for Republican
senators to vote with the Democrats and
say no we want to hear from john bolton
who has sent a lot of signals that he's
ready to basically burn the house down
so what's the likelihood for republicans
say nope we're gonna have a trial first
- well first of all again the Senate
gets to define the parameters of the
trial this is not like a standard
criminal trial during the Clinton
impeachment proceedings trial there were
no live witnesses there were excerpts of
videotaped depositions I don't know at
the end of the day whether there will be
live witnesses called there had been a
whole bunch of people who testified on
camera in front of the house to do
Intelligence Committee and deposition
transit understand let me let me finish
I don't know whether John Bolton will
testify I don't know whether Mick
Mulvaney will testify and if they do
they are wildcards same thing with
Hunter Biden
same thing with the whistleblower same
thing with atom shift these are all
unknowns Melanie is very confident that
this will not go so well for the
Republicans I am not so I'm not as
confident as she is that that is so I
really think John Bolton's gonna come
and say everything was I don't know what
Olson is going to say if I do not know
what John Bolton is going to say it's
very clear that he left on bad terms but
he also is aware of the fact that he was
the national security adviser and the
national security adviser advises the
president and it is up to the president
to make those decisions so I don't know
what John Bolton will say if called to
testify and I don't know whether he will
be called to testify and if he is it's a
gamble on both sides we have heard
numerous people say that he said you
know he didn't want to be any part of
that drug deal that like Sanderlin was
cooking up and he he definitely had the
view that what was happening was a
problem Fiona Hill has testified about
that so and it is clear John Bolton is
writing a book about this he has made it
clear that he has things to say and that
they would indeed be damaged he does
have things to say in fact he went with
his attorney into court and said I want
the court to tell me I'm having one side
that's given me a subpoena another side
has exerted executive privilege you tell
me what to say at that point the House
Democrats said nevermind and they would
drew their subpoena now they want to
hear from him again and I am sure that
he will say some things that will be
damaging to to the president he may also
have a thing or two to say that would be
damaging to the Democrats and regardless
of what it is the President does indeed
have a legitimate ability to be able to
decide whether he had a jaundiced view
of Ukraine and at the end of the day I
would remind people although I know
Melanie will say that this was only
because he had been uncovered which I do
not believe that the president not only
released the 391 million dollars after
militaries came to and after the vice
president and a bipartisan group of
senators had come to meet him in the
White House and it said there was strong
support for Ukraine and we believe the
president Solinsky and everybody knew
blurred come out and everybody knew that
this investigation was going to start
but we're gonna have a chance to talk
about this more as the day proceeds
because this cows hearing is going to go
on forever so
for now from Washington John Malcolm
Robinson Woodward burns melanie sloan
thank you so much for joining us we will
argue again in just a couple of hours
hopefully respectfully and by teaching
people a few things about what's going
on a lot to get to you today again a
historic day it's really just the
beginning and we'll have to see what
happens in the Senate that's where the
real fireworks could happen but for now
they are going to toss it back to Doha